gilles verdez tue son personnage et je
suis hyper angoisses et dudu j'ai le
vertige et tout [ __ ] il
gilles si tu ne peux pas sauter n'avais
pas mon sourire lutins c'est mon rêve
d'aller en laponie donc je vais faire
attention à d'autres sélections ferro
temps n'a pas aidé
j'ai sous les yeux de 0,81 point jeudi
la juge oui tu veux pas dire un petit
mois pato mais je les respecte
j attends tu peux pas dire est ce que tu
veux faire une déclaration d'amour à
quelqu'un avant de sauter peut-être
métro et c'est votre voix vous est ce
que vous pouvez parler cyril c'est fatou
que j'aime et votre voix me fait du bien
et surtout que de l'ormeau c'est un
scoop
si les attend s'ils ne sont pas on sera
des cours d'une voiture et est ce qu'il
reste des terreaux sexuelle dans cette
émission
gilles oui des fois tu vas dire un petit
mot avoue partir je suis terrifiée par
le vide dit pas les trucs comme ça mais
moi je suis de lormont la fesci bien sûr
vous le mexique n'est mignon nahla et
les boules
[Applaudissements]
el barka mais quelle dar k
bravo
[Applaudissements]